Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
menuda se está liando en África.
El golpe de Estado en Níger
significa mucho más que la típica
toma del poder por parte del Ejército.
Sí, es verdad que Níger es uno de los
países más pobres del mundo. Pero pese
a ello, tenía una democracia reconocida.
Tenía un Gobierno dispuesto a pedir ayuda
internacional para frenar a un yihadismo
que está haciendo del Sahel su territorio.
En este sentido, Níger era el gran aliado de
Occidente en el corazón del Sahel. Sin embargo,
ahora todo esto ha saltado por los aires con el
golpe de Estado de finales de julio. Ahora la
junta militar de Níger sigue buscando ayuda
extranjera. Pero quiere cambiar de aliados.
(La junta de Níger pide ayuda al grupo ruso
Wagner ante la amenaza de una
intervención militar. AP NEWS)
Pero esperad un momento, porque la intervención
militar no la puso sobre la mesa ninguna potencia
de Occidente, molesta por la creciente influencia
del Kremlin en África. Al menos no directamente.
Ha sido la CEDEAO, la Comunidad Económica de
Estados de África Occidental, la que no está
dispuesta a tolerar otro golpe militar y reclama
que regrese al poder Mohamed Bazoum, el presidente
depuesto de Níger. Y eso es exactamente lo que
ha hecho que suenen tambores de guerra en África.
N2(10 de agosto de 2023: Los líderes de África
Occidental organizan una "fuerza de reserva" para
responder al golpe de Estado en Níger. NY Times)
Y lo peor de todo es que esta intervención
militar podría ir más allá de Níger y
desencadenar un conflicto regional que
termine extendiéndose por múltiples países.
Así hablaba el portavoz de la junta militar,
el corone
Amadou Abdramane.
Abdramane no ha dudado en acusar a una
“potencia extranjera” de instigar y preparar
un ataque contra Niger. Por supuesto, se
refiere a Francia, su antigua metrópoli.
De hecho, la junta militar ha roto todos los
acuerdos militares de Níger con Francia. El
Gobierno de Macron se limitó a indicar que apoya
la intervención de la CEDEAO. Por lo tanto,
ya estáis viendo cómo se están poniendo las cosas.
Así que os estaréis preguntando: ¿Por qué se ha
producido este golpe de Estado en Níger? ¿Qué
papel juega Rusia en todo esto? Y sobre todo,
¿A cuántos países puede terminar salpicando
este conflicto? En VisualPolitik hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas, pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
T1(LA
ÚLTIMA DEMOCRACIA DEL SAHEL)
El Sahel es una estrecha franja
de tierra al sur del desierto del Sáhara
caracterizada por su altísima pobreza.
En el centro del Sahel se sitúan
4 países; de oeste a este: Malí,
Burkina Faso, Níger y Chad. Pues bien, todos
ellos tienen varias cosas en común. Para empezar,
ninguno de estos países tiene salida al mar;
además, en los 4 se habla francés, con lo que ya
sabéis cuál era la potencia colonial; asimismo
son mayoritariamente de religión musulmana.
Y ahora también tienen otra cosa en común:
en todos ellos ya gobiernan los militares
después del golpe de Estado que ha puesto
punto final a la VII República de Níger.
Y sí, más de uno estará pensando: pero a ver
Alberto, si Níger consiguió la independencia
de Francia en 1960, 63 años y 7 Repúblicas
sale a 9 años por República. Pues sí,
pero es que estabilidad y Níger son dos
palabras que no suelen ir de la mano.
(No obstante, todo parecía haber cambiado
a partir del año 2010. Un golpe militar a
favor de la democracia desalojó del
poder al presidente Mamadou Tandja,
un hombre que había sido elegido en las urnas
pero que aspiraba a perpetuarse en el poder y
convertir a Níger en un régimen autoritario.
La transición contó con el acompañamiento de
la comunidad internacional y dio lugar a la
Constitución de la VII República. Un período
que en 2021 pudo ver el primer traspaso
pacífico de poder entre presidentes.)
Sin embargo, amigos, el Sahel ha
visto en la última década cómo una
grave amenaza desestabilizaba toda la
región. Estamos hablando del yihadismo.
El fanatismo religioso encuentra sus soldados
entre los desesperados y muchas veces hambrientos
habitantes de estos países del Sahel. Son
personas que han nacido en uno de los peores
lugares del mundo; y los yihadistas les prometen
un presente mejor y un futuro en el paraíso.
Y, claro, el problema es que la alternativa
es la agricultura de subsistencia, de la que
en Níger malvive más del 80% de la población.
De hecho, la pobreza extrema alcanza a casi la
mitad de todos los habitantes del país.
Son cifras que en los 13 años de la VII
República apenas se han podido revertir.
Hablamos de datos muy similares a los de
países vecinos como Malí y Burkina Faso. Ambos
han tenido golpes de Estado en los últimos 3
años que acabaron con la democracia: Malí en
2021 y Burkina Faso en 2022. En ambos casos,
los militares tomaron el poder con el pretexto
de acabar con el yihadismo. Sin embargo,
amigos, han conseguido todo lo contrario.
Mirad este mapa elaborado por la empresa
estadounidense StratFor sobre incidentes violentos
en el Sahel entre agosto de 2021 y agosto de 2022.
La guerra contra el yihadismo ha disparado la
violencia. En 2022 las muertes por el yihadismo
en el Sahel aumentaron un 75%, a más de 10.000.
El caos se impone. Y la junta militar de Malí
ha recurrido a los Wagner. En Burkina Faso el
gobierno apenas controla el 40% del país. En
Níger la situación no es tan extrema, pero
también actúan los mismos grupos yihadistas
que asolan Malí y Burkina Faso. Hablamos de
filiales de Al-Qaeda y del Daesh; asimismo sufre
constantes ataques de Boko Haram y del Estado
Islámico en su zona fronteriza con Nigeria.
Sin embargo, a diferencia de lo que pasa en
Burkina Faso y en Mali, el último año en Níger
estaba siendo el menos mortífero desde el 2018.
Y, ¿Cuál es la razón para que exista esta
diferencia? Pues ni más ni menos
que el enfoque adoptado en Níger
por el Gobierno de Mohamed Bazoum contra el
yihadismo. Su estrategia tiene varias patas:
Primero, la ayuda militar occidental,
fundamentalmente la prestada por Francia y Estados
Unidos; segundo, la mejora de los servicios del
Estado en las áreas más deprimidas; y tercero,
otras iniciativas que son tan opuestas a la guerra
contra el yihadismo como evidentemente polémicas:
(Níger: Mohamed Bazoum libera a
"terroristas" para abrir el diálogo)
El plan de desmovilización respaldado por
Bazoum prometió reintegrar en la sociedad
a los yihadistas que depusieran las
armas. Nada más: diálogo a cambio
de una tregua; libertad a cambio de la paz.
Desde el punto de vista occidental, conversar
con los terroristas es mala idea: implica ceder a
sus chantajes y abre la puerta a que se produzcan
nuevos ataques para lograr nuevas cesiones.
Sin embargo, en un país como Níger, hay que poner
en una balanza el poder real que tiene el Estado
y la fuerza de los grupos terroristas. Si la lucha
está equilibrada, ir a la guerra puede ser todo
un desastre para la población. Hay que explorar
otras vías. Y claro, hay quien no está dispuesto
a tolerar la más mínima señal de debilidad.
Así se pronunciaba el nuevo presidente de
Níger, el general Omar Tchiani, al justificar
su golpe de Estado por el supuesto deterioro
de la seguridad provocado por el yihadismo.
Esta es la misma excusa que los golpistas
dieron en Malí y en Burkina Faso. Pero amigos,
ya habéis visto que los datos de Níger son
bastante diferentes. Así que algo más tiene que
haber. La pregunta es, ¿el qué? Pues posiblemente
sean ciertos los rumores previos al golpe de que
el general Tchiani iba a ser destituido
como el jefe de la guardia presidencial.
No perdáis de vista que es la guardia
presidencial la que da el golpe tomando
como rehén al presidente Bazoum. El Ejército
tuvo que pronunciarse después. Mirad:
(El ejército de Níger respalda el
golpe contra el líder pro-occidental
para evitar un "baño de sangre". FT)
Pero bueno, tampoco merece la pena
darle muchas más vueltas a todo esto.
Al fin y al cabo, son militares dando
un golpe de Estado para hacerse por el poder.
Sea por ambición personal o por descontento
nacional, por una razón o por otra es el pan
nuestro de cada día en el continente africano.
Sin embargo, amigos, esta vez, se han
topado con el rechazo frontal de una
organización regional como la CEDEAO. Una
organización que parece dispuesta a todo
con tal de restaurar la democracia en Níger.
Y mucho ojo, que no sería la primera vez.
T2(ECOS DE GUERRA)
La CEDEAO es una organización integrada por
15 países de África Occidental entre los que
se encuentra Níger. En un principio
se trata de una organización con un
propósito económico al formar un único bloque
comercial. Pero esperad un momento, amigos,
porque la CEDEAO también ha movilizado fuerzas de
paz en la región e intervino en países miembros en
momentos de gran inestabilidad. En los últimos 30
años han actuado en Sierra Leona, Guinea Bissau,
Costa de Marfil, Liberia, Malí y Gambia.
(La última intervención militar de la CEDEAO
fue en 2017 en Gambia. Después de dos décadas en
el poder, Yahya Jammeh se resistía a abandonar el
timón de mando y cederlo a Adama Barrow, que
había ganado las elecciones presidenciales.
La CEDEAO entonces formó una coalición de
tropas de Senegal, Ghana y Nigeria y se
dispuso a invadir Gambia. Yahya Jammeh renunció
a los 3 días y la democracia fue restaurada.)
Sin embargo, amigos, Níger no es Gambia. Su
territorio es 100 veces más grande y su Ejército,
además de ser más numeroso, cuenta con años de
entrenamiento por parte de fuerzas occidentales.
Así que la intervención militar es compleja y
supondría asumir muchos más riesgos. El primero,
el de la propia vida del presidente Bazoum, que no
está en el exilio sino en manos de los golpistas.
N5(Funcionarios occidentales: La junta de Níger
advirtió de que mataría al presidente depuesto si
se produjese una intervención militar. ABC News)
Además, seguro que muchos os estáis preguntando
por qué la CEDEAO se ha mostrado ahora
tan firme y tajante ante Níger cuando
recientemente también hubo golpes de
Estado similares en Malí y Burkina Faso.
Pues bien, la clave de todo la tiene
una persona: Bola Tinubu. Es el nuevo
presidente de Nigeria desde el
pasado mayo. Tinubu ha tenido el
tiempo suficiente para que a principios
de julio le nombraran presidente de la
CEDEAO. Un cargo representativo desde el que
lanzó este mensaje en su toma de posesión:
En su discurso también defendió la democracia, la
libertad y el estado de Derecho. Y todo esto son
mucho más que las palabras de Bola Tinubu. Son
la carta de presentación del nuevo presidente de
Nigeria ante la CEDEAO, ante el continente
africano e, incluso, ante el mundo entero.
Al fin y al cabo no podemos olvidar el
enorme peso que tiene Nigeria. Hablamos
de la gran potencia africana junto a
Egipto y Sudáfrica. Y, por supuesto,
es quien lleva la voz cantante de la CEDEAO.
Al margen de su preocupación por que Níger
corra la misma suerte de Malí y Burkina
Faso y se dispare la violencia en la zona,
Nigeria quiere asumir su papel de líder regional.
Y claro, el golpe de Níger tuvo lugar apenas 3
semanas después del discurso de Tinubu.
Así que, mientras la diplomacia siga sin
dar resultados, los preparativos
militares seguirán su curso. La
credibilidad de Bola Tinubu está en juego.
El contingente de la CEDEAO para la invasión
de Níger puede ascender a 25.000.
Radio France Internationale.)
Más de la mitad del contingente sería
aportado por Nigeria. Por su parte,
también han confirmado que enviarán tropas
Senegal, Costa de Marfil y Benín. Y luego,
hay otros dos países con efectivos sobre
el terreno: uno es Francia. La antigua
potencia colonial está siendo utilizada por
los golpistas como el chivo expiatorio. Todo
lo malo de Níger es culpa de Francia.
Y de hecho, los golpistas han atacado
su embajada e incluso acusaron al Gobierno
de Macron de liberar terroristas. Es más,
no queremos mostrar imágenes desagradables, pero
los golpistas llenaron un estadio de fútbol y
la gente les vitoreaba mientras decapitaban
un gallo pintado con la bandera de Francia.
Seguro que con todo esto ya os hacéis una
idea del rechazo que tienen hacia Francia.
Pues bien, los galos mantienen allí una base
permanente, equipada con aviones de combate,
drones Reaper y 1.500 soldados. El Gobierno
de Macron ha dicho que apoya los esfuerzos
de la CEDEAO para devolver el poder a Bazoum.
Ahora bien, lo más probable es que no se mueva
ni un soldado francés, no sea que la junta
militar haya llegado para quedarse y le dé
por revisar acuerdos como el del pasado mayo.
(5 de mayo, 2023: Níger: acuerdo firmado con
la francesa Orano para la explotación
de yacimientos de uranio hasta 2040)
Está claro que el interés de Francia es
continuar explotando el uranio de Níger,
que ha sido su tercer mayor proveedor
durante las últimas décadas.
Luego, el otro país que tiene tropas en Níger es
Estados Unidos. En total son más de mil efectivos,
desplegados en varias bases de drones.
De momento, la Casa Blanca está apostando
por la vía diplomática. Pero le
están pidiendo pasar a la acción.
(El líder derrocado de Níger dice
que es un rehén e insta a Estados
Unidos a detener el golpe. NBC News)
El expresidente lo pidió ni más ni menos
que en una carta al Washington Post.
Sí, parece difícil de entender,
¿qué clase de golpistas dejan que su prisionero
se comunique libremente con el exterior? Porque
después del golpe, Bazoum puso un tweet e
incluso ha hablado por teléfono con Blinken,
con [Sharl Mishél] Charles Michel, con Borrell…
vamos, que solo le faltó hacerse youtuber.
Ahora bien, ni la Casa Blanca, ni la Unión
Europea están consiguiendo avances en las
negociaciones con la junta militar
de Níger. Los golpistas han rechazado
incluso recibir una delegación tripartita
compuesta por representantes de la CEDEAO,
la Unión Africana y la ONU.
Y es que, ¿Sabéis qué? Los militares
tienen muy claro cuál quieren que sea el lugar
de Níger en el mundo y sus aliados. Atentos.
T3(MÁS ALLÁ DEL MURO)
Las juntas militares
de Malí y Burkina Faso nos ofrecen la hoja de
ruta a seguir por el golpista africano moderno:
Lo primero es atacar a la antigua
potencia colonial por todas las vías
posibles. Ellos tienen que tener la culpa de todo.
En el caso Níger, sin ir más lejos, ya os hemos
mostrado algún ejemplo. Pero esperad un momento,
porque todavía pueden hacer más contra Francia.
En Malí, por ejemplo, eliminaron el francés
como lengua oficial y en este país y en Burkina
Faso echaron a todas las tropas francesas que
estaban allí combatiendo el yihadismo. Casi nada.
Sea como sea, el siguiente paso sería
tomar posiciones dentro de este mundo
multipolar. Y en Níger ya han elegido.
(Los sastres de Níger se apresuran a
fabricar banderas rusas tras el golpe)
Los golpistas han creado en África una
franja de países dirigidos por militares que se
extiende desde el océano Atlántico hasta el mar
Rojo. La mayoría de estos países están ahora
más alineados con Rusia que con Occidente.
Y no solo eso, sino que pretenden levantar un
muro frente a la antaño indiscutible influencia
occidental. Amigos, ni Rusia ni Wagner
están involucrados en los preparativos
del golpe de Estado de Níger. Pero
una vez que este se ha producido,
ambos están dispuestos a sacar provecho. Wagner se
propaga por África como si de un virus se tratara.
(Antes del motín de Prigozhin, los mercenarios
del grupo Wagner formaban parte del catálogo de
servicios ofrecidos por Rusia en sus negociaciones
diplomáticas. De este modo es como Wagner llegó
a países como la República Centroafricana
o Malí, donde los regímenes autoritarios
contratan a los hombres de Prigozhin para
hacer el trabajo sucio. Mientras tanto,
el Kremlin desplaza a Occidente como
la potencia influyente en la zona.)
Putin está muy interesado en África, tal y como
se ha escenificado en la cumbre que se acaba
de celebrar en San Petersburgo. Así que todo
indica que Prigozhin seguirá adelante con sus
operaciones en el continente africano mientras
siga resultando útil a los propósitos de Putin.
Y ya visteis al principio del vídeo que la junta
militar de Níger ha pedido ayuda al Grupo Wagner.
Un grupo que en República Centroafricana, en Malí,
en Sudán, allí se han hecho con el control de las
minas de oro y de diamantes. ¿Qué tiene Níger
para Wagner? Pues… Fundamentalmente uranio.
Privar a Europa del uranio nigerino dibujaría
una sonrisa en los rostros de Putin y Prigozhin,
pero no parece demasiado atractivo para los
mercenarios rusos. Se necesita algo más. Y bueno,
Níger cuenta con alguna que otra mina de
oro. Y también tiene petróleo. De hecho,
Níger aspiraba este año a multiplicar
por 5 su modesta producción de crudo.
El caso es que, como bien sabéis los
que sois habituales de VisualPolitik,
Wagner siempre saca tajada. Aun así, esta
es la menor de las preocupaciones de la
junta militar. La intervención de la CEDEAO es su
prioridad número 1. Y todo apunta a que en caso
de producirse finalmente la intervención,
los golpistas de Níger no estarían solos.
(Burkina Faso y Malí dicen que
la intervención militar en Níger
sería una 'declaración de guerra'. France24)
El muro de los golpistas se está fortificando.
Y mucho ojo porque Argelia y Guinea también han
mostrado su rechazo a la intervención militar.
Mientras tanto la CEDEAO continúa presionando
a la junta militar de Tchiani al ordenar la
movilización de su fuerza de reserva para
restablecer el orden constitucional en Níger. Este
conflicto amenaza con involucrar directamente a
un montón de países africanos que ya han dicho que
tomarán las armas para defender sus posiciones.
En VisualPolitik seguiremos atentos a este
conflicto incipiente. Pero ahora la
pregunta es para ti: ¿Creéis que la
CEDEAO conseguirá restaurar la democracia en
Níger? ¿Se involucrará directamente alguna
potencia ajena al continente africano? Déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios. Si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like y compártelo
con tus amigos. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.